so rape climbing is one of the very best
new exercises that I've introduced into
my regime and I think that everyone
should be doing it for some pretty
impressive results so rope climbing is
something that a lot of people don't
think that they can do at home they
think they need to be in a gymnastics
Hall with a really tall rope several
meters up in the air and a spotter
watchman to make sure they don't fall
well that's obviously awesome that's not
the only way to use rope climbs in fact
if use a much shorter rope you can
safely train with this at home and build
awesome grip strength bicep strength
core strength and work capacity yeah so
the way you do this is simply to get a
pull-up bar and then get a rope that's a
810 foot long and then attach that to
the pull-up bar and then climb up and
down that I bought a rope on eBay that
cost about 30 quid and it came with
eyelets ready inserted and then I just
added two carabiners to be on the safe
side to my pull-up bar and loop them
through my pull-up bar also came with a
small hoop especially for that kind of
thing which obviously is convenient but
if you don't have that you can easily
just tie a rope to a tree branch or
around a pull-up bar that could be ones
in your doorframe even you could even
use towels or a bedsheet and tie them in
knots as long as it can take your weight
anything is fair game now obviously this
is gonna be much shorter it's not going
to give you a whole lot of space for
climbing really high but that's fine
because if you're mainly training for
strength and grip strength and work
capacity then you have to do just a few
reaches with your hands is more than
enough you can climb to the top and then
back down and then to the top and then
back down or you can climb to the top
drop down to the ground and then repeat
repeat repeat this works fine for our
purposes and of course it also means you
can need to keep your legs up in the air
so you can either be in the v-sit
position or you can just keep your legs
kind of flailing upwards either way you
can be training your core this way as
well making it even more effective as a
muscle building and a functional
strength building exercise obviously if
you're doing proper rope climbs as a
gymnast or as a Navy SEAL you'd be using
something like the j-hook technique or
other methods to clamp your feet to the
rope so become more of a legs exercise
and you'll be focusing on efficiency
climbing as far as you can without
burning yourself out but because we're
actively trying to train our biceps and
burn ourselves out we don't need in
space to be able to use our legs in fact
it's kind of a bonus that we can't it
forces us to use the harder version of
this exercise and like I said this is
fantastic for your grip strength for
obvious reasons and as you get better
you can increase the thickness of the
rope which will make it even harder on
your grip and your forearm strength and
everything else at the same time it's
brilliant your biceps practice is often
cited as one of the reasons that
gymnasts in particular have such massive
arms and if you want to see someone
who's got massive arms lengths of rope
climbing check out Ross ethically he
climbed a rope for the cumulative
distance of Mount Everest and by doing
that he built huge biceps that huge to
this day and this is also thanks to
another advantage of rope climbing if
you only climb up then it's a concentric
only exercise what that means is you're
only contracting the muscle and never
elongating it under pressure
elongating your muscle under pressure is
one of the best ways to create
micro-tears and muscle damage and
stimulate hypertrophy if you only
contract the muscle then you create a
lot less damage and a lot less
inflammation and that means you can use
huge rep ranges of concentric only
exercises and even train it every single
day without needing as long to recover
without risking overtraining obviously I
don't recommend that the average doe do
this however it's a useful tool to have
in your arsenal for most of us we want
to climb back down we might even want to
slow down that descent because that way
we're creating lots of muscle damage and
we can build this really big biceps at
the same time like I said wrote
climbing's fantastic for work capacity
because you're constantly moving you can
do these four huge rep ranges and you're
never letting up with the tension
because you need to hold onto the Rope
at all times even in between reps using
your whole body as well and yeah the
fact that you're using a whole body it's
really evident in just how much your abs
will hurt from doing this and how much
you'll develop your core over time
because as you climb with the rope not
using your legs you can have to put them
somewhere that means you're using a
static contraction with your abs and in
order to swing your body create the
torque you need to use the movement to
climb the rope it's a full-body really
functional exercise and what's really
cool about it is it has a real world
direct application you can imagine using
rope climbs to scale a building like a
ninja or rappel down it when you're
breaking through a roof to stop some
terrorists it's just a really cool
awesome way to Train there's a lot of
fun as well which is what I really like
about it when I'm training with rope
climbs what I like to do is climb
the rope and then climb all around my
pull-up bar because it's got multiple
attachments and do things like front
levers and maybe a quick one arm to pull
up and things like that drop down onto
the rope and just really experiment with
the movement and that's a really fun way
to Train it's really varied and there's
a small element of risk and all this
means that ya really don't get bored and
I'm using that kind of training of
course this is also a fantastic way to
build up to one arm to pull up because
essentially that's what you're doing
every time you reach up the rope you're
holding your weight with one arm
before you get started though there are
a few safety considerations to bear in
mind and a few technique tips this is
really intense on your elbow tendons and
if you dive straight into high volume
rope climbs or rope crowns with some
kind of added weight then you're going
to really quickly damage your elbows and
this can put you out of action for a
long time so I recommend that you build
up that elbow that straight arm strength
before you start doing your rope crimes
you can do this with supper nated
support holds on the rings or rings
turned out push up so you can do it with
pseudo planche you can do it with
Maltese push-ups or you can do it with
the crow pose or any kind of straight
arm training like that and of course by
introducing low-volume rope climbs just
taking it easy to begin with really
build up to this carefully if you feel
any pain in your elbows stop immediately
another tip is to always keep your arms
bent don't dangle from your arm with a
straight arm because that's a very quick
way to injure yourself at the same time
you should try and have your hands at
about face level when you cross over and
twist your grip inwards when you hold on
to the rope this will not only allow you
to get harder and reduce the chances of
you slipping down and hurting yourself
but it will also take some of the
pressure off of those elbows thereby
preventing injury further you should
always be engaged always have tension in
the arms this is part of the big benefit
of rope climbing and it'll prevent you
from hurting yourself there are plenty
of variations you can use if you can't
do rope climbs right away some easier
options are just to hold onto the rope
and pull yourself up and down like a
strange pull-up likewise you can use
wall climbs if you can install the rope
somewhere where there's a wall or a tree
trunk and you can kick the legs against
it and scale it like that ninja these
are also great options for mechanical
drop sets do as much rope climbing as
you can and when you can't do anymore
swap to one of these easier variations
as you get really good
and it gets too easy for you then you
can introduce a weighted vest and this
really increases the challenge what I've
been doing lately and yeah I've seen
crazy benefits from rope climbing it's
really changed my physique especially as
I haven't been out to get to the gym as
much lately
I haven't be able to rely on some of my
old favorites like heavy benchpress as
much so I hope you found this video
useful let me know in the comments down
below if you use rope climbs or what
other unusual training techniques or
tools you using in your training head
over to the website for the full article
and also I'd like to take this
opportunity to announce that I am
working on an e-book a massive ebook is
already 70 thousand words long which is
going to also include a full training
program it's called super functional
training functional training means doing
all the things that your body was
designed to be able to do super
functional training means being able to
do things that you don't need to be able
to do but are awesome and at the same
time it also incorporates brain training
a single program for training your body
and mind and it's all laid out it's all
explained and it also includes
descriptions of all the exercises along
with diet plans recipes and loads and
loads of information so if that sounds
cool then stay tuned I'll be announcing
more about it soon lots of people in
requesting this and that's why I decided
to finally do it it's also why I've been
a bit slow with output on occasion if
you want to be notified about that sign
up to the Facebook page I'll leave the
link in the description down below head
over there and I'll be announcing more
details very soon I'll also be giving
several people a kind of preview copy
for free so they can tell me how they
found it give me any feedback so if you
want to be one of those people head over
there and look out for that post anyways
either way please subscribe to the
channel stay tuned for more content like
this and I'll see you next time thanks a
ton for watching and bye for now